Let's go next to Rob from Massachusetts. Rob
from Massachusetts. What's going on today?
I'm doing good. How you
doing? Doing well. Doing well.
I just want to say I've been
watching your program for,
I think five, six months. I think I first
found out about you through Fantino Butut.
Yeah. Are you familiar with Burlington, by
any chance? Burlington, Masser, Vermont,
Burlington, Mass.
I've been in Burlington, Mass. Once.
Oh, you have.
All right, so let me just
get to my question, I want to there's one break,
Gesell, but oh, I didn't know if the question was
related to Burlington, so I was answering it as
if it was material. Yes, I should have got to the
question. So my question for you is, I will. I've
kind of been raised to kind of think that, Rob.
Democrats are bad based on like my
family's beliefs. And as I've gotten older,
I've noticed that my own siblings have kind
of grown a lot more aware of how different in
how vastly different we kind of think in
political beliefs. So my question for you is.
How do you kind of stem away from
your what families have taught
you in politics and just be comfortable
with the decisions you make in politics?
This is a very, very important question,
because there's certainly no question that
people are more likely to hold the political
beliefs that line up with their parents. As a
general rule, and of course, there's people that
abandon left wing parents and become right wing
and there's people that abandon right wing parents
and become left wing. I think the important thing
to do is to separate it from being a lot of
times political and also religious beliefs are
sort of considered sacred and different than any
other kind of belief. So there's not much stigma
or shame or concern. Typically, if your parents
grew up liking American cars and you think Ford,
Chevy and Dodge, they're not that great. I really
prefer German vehicles or something like that.
And I think what's important is if you feel
confident in that, understand that coming to
different conclusions about religion or politics,
if it's based on facts and empiricism, really is
no different. Now, it's easier said than done
because it's much more likely that your family
is going to judge you. If you have different
political beliefs than they do. Whereas if you
have a different opinion about which airline to
fly or what foods taste good or what cars to buy,
it's unlikely to create the same type of rift. But
if the question is how to feel confident in your
beliefs, I think it's the destigmatizing of Paul
political and religious beliefs so that you might
just look at the facts in a different way. You
might look at facts. Your parents didn't look at
and come to different conclusions and that that
is OK. And then the second piece that's tougher is
figuring out, you know, if and how it affects your
relationship with them. And that's tougher to do.
No, I feel I could make it
all that difficult. Like as
and the scenario when I eventually move
out and assuming that things pick up
once Cauvin clears up. Yes, hopefully.
We all hope it will be soon and we all
hope it will happen. And, you know, it could be
a little while, but hopefully not too long, Rob.
No, definitely. Thank you
again for taking my question.
I'm glad that I'm glad that you're
staying strong through all this.
And congrats on the million subscriber milestone.
That's a huge I know it's like a huge milestone
for our people, but I'm happy out of all. Out
of all the political commentators on YouTube,
I'm glad that you've made it this
far. So congrats on that, man.
Thank you. And almost now, at one
point, one million subscribers. Very,
very. So I would love to get to one point one,
honestly. By Election Day, I don't know that
that's going to happen. But anyway, we will. We
will. We will continue trying. And we will see.